The Joe Rogan experience of,
you know,
occasionally I'll have my lungs
checked and they tell me they're great.
Isn't that amazing? It's crazy, you
know, because I think if you keep active,
you know, like you train and, and, and uh,
a lot of us train now I go this
generation, they're not like lazy stoners.
They don't just sit back and do nothing.
There still are those. But you know,
I don't think it has the, the
same carcinogens is, you know,
people expect it, you know, like a
cigarette. It does. And so, you know,
you might look at someone's lungs who,
who,
who smoked cigarettes and you might
see something there and like, hey,
you need to, you know, slow the
fuck down over here. But in,
in every time that I've had my lungs
checked or whatever, for whatever,
whether I've, you know, gotten
sick or whatever, they're,
they're always telling me lungs,
they're in good shape.
And it's a funny thing
because, you know, in they can,
1987,
you know,
I was 17 and I was gang banging,
I got shot.
And you know that I got hit by a
22 in it as hollow points do it.
Um, it, it broke into three, three pieces.
The hollow point in one of them
punctured my lung on my left side.
And uh, you know, they were telling me,
uh, well you know, um, do you smoke?
No, I don't really smoke cause
I didn't smoke cigarettes.
I smoked weed but I wasn't going to
divulge that at the time I was 17 and you
know, and uh, they said, well you know,
well that's good because
you'll never smoke again.
It's like they punctured
your lung and Blah Blah Blah.
They thought I was going to have to
work off one lung but in the three days,
you know,
they were able to get the blood out of
the lung and I was able to get it back,
you know, through the exercises
they told me, you know,
to get it back to its regular size and
I've never had a problem since then.
Knock on the piece of metal out.
No, I still got the three pieces.
That's like when I go do my physicals
and they do the, you know, the,
the Mris and the x rays and all
that. The doctors, you know,
sometimes they forget because they see
so many patients. Is Mr Freeze, um,
these appeared to be bullet fragments.
What,
what is that? Well, you just
said it doctor bullet Fred,
you've seen him a dozen
times, you know, and uh,
yeah I was very lucky. I was
very lucky because, you know,
punctured my lung and then two of
the pieces, one was by the heart,
one was by my spine,
but I was at a Martin Luther King
Hospital in Linwood and we call that place
killer king because you go in there for
something small and ended up dying or
come out, you know, gift out
or something. So you know,
I wasn't going to allow them to try and
get to those bullets or those fragments
to open you up. Yeah. No,
no, no, no. Cause you know,
they didn't have a great success rate.
What kind of lung exercise they
give you try to pump your lens bag.
They give you this breathing apparatus
that has like a ball in it, right?
And it has two lines and you know this,
it's the first line you're trying to,
they're telling you every day for five
minutes to 10 minutes to blow that,
you know,
not all in one shot but like to keep
practicing getting the ball up there and
that will then help inflate
the lung and get it back.
So I had to do that for probably
like three weeks. And uh,
you know, the puncture wound, it
healed itself pretty much. And uh,
and the pieces are still in your lung?
Not In the lung? No, it went passed along.
It, that shot passed along.
So you know, it's uh,
I got a piece up here and one
off to the side in the back.
Well when it's really cold due
to the, the, the nerve damage,
I'll get like stinging like you know, like
when your, when your hand falls asleep,
the little needles that
I'll get that here and then,
and then back here where it entered,
they had,
they had to cut right in between a rib
here to stick the tube in to put the hose
into the lung to get the blood out of
the lung. Dang. Yeah. Uh, as you know,
I was living crazy before
I got into the music.
The music saved my life
pretty much. Really? Yeah. How
long were you gang bang for?
Ooh, for, for some years. You know,
I started, I started young. Um,
I was probably 13 years old.
Whoa Gang Bang. And then,
and uh, I got out of it probably,
I didn't necessarily get out,
but I changed up what I was doing cause
you don't ever really get out per se
unless they jump you out and you know,
I was too into it to be
jumped out like that.
You know what I mean? That
wasn't something I was going
to do because, you know,
for as negative as it was,
it taught me a lot. Um,
so my, my boys that I, you know, ran with,
they understood I was trying to
do something different. You know,
I made a choice to try the music and
leave that shit alone because there,
there was no way that you do both.
If you do both,
do you see the results of that?
What's happening today with a lot of cats?
You know what I mean?
That they try to ride the line,
be professional and be in the music,
but they're still kind of in this
world over here. And when it bleeds in,
one bleeds into the other, it, you know,
it fucks everything up, you know? And, uh,
so I chose,
you know,
I was going to do music and just talk
about those life experiences and whatnot.
And that was probably it.
I'm 18 that a,
I started taking on the music and uh,
that's, that's where it went. You know,
like when you said you learned a lot
from it, like what did you learn from it?
Well, you know, your
street, you know, there's,
there's common sense and then
there's common sense on the streets.
And then there's being aware
and looking out and you know,
not being a doormat and, uh, just,
it's a whole different type of schooling
when you're gang banging, you know,
that's the way you, uh, carry yourself,
the way you communicate with someone and
know whether they're disrespecting you
or not and how you deal with that
disrespect, which is, you know,
a whole different world in the
gang bang shit. But it's a,
it's a different kind of education. You
know, I wouldn't, I wouldn't take it back.
Some of the things I would,
you know,
I definitely regretted while I
was doing it for sure. But, um,
it made me see things from a different
perspective, you know, and, and why,
you know, things are the way they are
in gangs and stuff like that from lack,
lack of opportunities, you know, for,
for these kids to be doing something,
you know, cause not everybody's
good at sports, you know,
but there has to be other opportunities
other than other than that to get kids
interested in doing something else
because falling into the gangs, it's,
it's easy if you don't have
a good home life at home.
The guys on the street are your second
family and they eventually become your
first family. You know what I mean? And
if you don't have a father figure at home,
one of the guys in the gang,
you know, becomes your mentor,
he could become like the guy you look up
to as like your father figure. You know,
there's that. And then, you know, again,
there's not enough programs out there
to keep people into doing something
different than falling into that. And
then sometimes, you know, it just,
it's a matter of, you know, you
growing up in this neighborhood,
if you have to walk down that street
and they approach you and say, Hey,
you live in this hood, you got
to be with us. If you don't,
we're going to make it hard for you.
So there's that peer pressure and
then there's the legacy shit. Like,
so if my father was a gangster in
this gang and he still lives in this
neighborhood,
pressure's on for me eventually
to take up where father left off,
you know? And uh, it's,
it's all those things.
And then some people just start thrill
seekers and they choose and have nothing
in common with none of that.
They just choose it for some people too.
It's so appealing to have
somewhere that you belong right in.
And that's the thing,
because if you don't feel like you
belong in your school or you don't belong
with your,
in your family and that,
that she can totally take hold
in, you end up there. You know,
fortunately, I had good friends
that weren't gang bangers. You know,
that they had talent for music, which is
mugs and sin, and sends brother Mellow.
You know, they were, you know, I
did music as a hobby, you know,
before I got into gangs.
And they got me back into
the music because they
recognized something in me and
said, hey, we want you to come back where
we got these opportunities over here.
Come join us.
[inaudible].